[Musique]
quelle est la principale différence
entre l'homme et la machine
en fait cette question et nous obsède
depuis au-moins l'antiquité
l'at on essayait déjà y répondre et
invariablement quand on vous pose la
question quand on se pose cette question
c'est toujours la même qui revient au
premier ce sont les émotions ce qu'on va
essayer de voir ensemble c est ce qu il
est possible qu'une machine ressentent
des émotions
est ce qu'une intelligence artificielle
peut ressentir des émotions et on va
voir qu'il ya plusieurs étapes pour y
arriver si c'est possible
la première c'est représenter les être
capable de représenter de manière
artificielle des émotions et ça on sait
le faire depuis pratiquement la nuit des
temps ici vous avez une image d'un
masque nos japonais et ils l'expriment
parfaitement des émotions en fait toute
l'histoire de l'art nous montre qu'on
est capable d'exprimer des émotions que
tout à chacun est capable de reconnaître
donc le problème il est pas là
aujourd'hui on sait exprimer les
émotions avec des avatars avec des
robots le deuxième problème c'est
reconnaître les émotions des autres
alors 7 pendant de longues années ça a
été difficile et aujourd'hui avec des
progrès justement en intelligence
artificielle
on est capable de le faire on est
capable d'analyser l'image on est
capable de reconnaître certains motifs
dans du son breakout dire voilà mon
interlocuteur il est dans cet état
émotionnel mais c'est pas suffisant
exprimer les émotions reconnaître les
émotions chez ses interlocuteurs c'est
pas suffisant il faut que la créature
artificielle l'intelligence artificielle
soit caplanne elle même est bien de
ressentir ses émotions en tout cas de
d'avoir quelque chose qui simule ce
ressenti l'émotion chez nous tout se
passe dans le cerveau
donc ça et le cerveau c'est une machine
hypercomplexes 100 milliards de cellules
interconnectées entre elles
c'est probablement l'objet le plus
complexe qu'on connaisse aujourd'hui
dans l'univers en tout cas en ce qui
nous concerne donc est ce qu'on peut
avec une machine essayer de reproduire
cette histoire d'émotion qui se trouve
finalement dans notre cerveau alors
c'est une question également assez
ancienne mais bon par rapport aux grecs
et les plus récentes dans l'histoire les
premiers à se poser la question de
reproduire dans une machine
la structure du cerveau ce sont ma
culotte et pitts en 1943 qui étudie en
fait la structure d'un neurone arous
avait ce neurones c'est une cellule 1
comme toutes les cellules de notre corps
avec un corps cellulaire un noyau avec
de l'adn
mais cette cellule a cette particularité
étrange et bien d'avoir des entrées qui
répondent à des stimuli électriques
et puis une sortie l'axone qui va
communiquer la réponse ce qu'a calculé
entre guillemets le neurone et macule ok
pitts en 1943 eh bien il invente un
modèle formelle un modèle mathématique
abstrait de ce neurones en essayant de
retrouver ses caractéristiques et ils
vont démontrer en particulier malgré sa
simplicité parce que cet automate
c'est un petit tomates relativement
simple que je vais vous décrire et bien
en en mettant un certain nombre et bien
ça peut calculer à peu près tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer il n'y a pas de
limite
c'est une machine universel alors à quoi
ça ressemble un neurone abstrait pour
ceux qui font de l'intelligence
artificielle au moins à l'époque de ma
culotte et pitt s'est versé à plusieurs
entrées comme le neurone naturel à cette
époque là on est les fanas des 0 et des
1 donc elle va y avoir du binaire à
l'entrée et sur chacune de ses entrées
eh bien on met un coefficient et le
calcul va être extrêmement simple on va
multiplier l'entrée par ce coefficient
ça va permettre de donner finalement
l'importance de cette entrée par rapport
aux autres et ensuite on fait une
addition est ce qu'on va parler en
mathématiques de somme pondérée un terme
un peu compliqué pour dire simplement on
prend les entrées en lait multiplient et
on fait une somme est juste derrière
cette somme on obtient un an
eh bien on va prendre un seuil et si le
nombre qu'on obtient est supérieure à ce
seuil alors le neurone va sortir 1 1
dans le cas contraire si on est
inférieure à ce seuil il va sortir 1-0
oui c'est une machine relativement
simple et malgré ça elle est capable
si on en met un certain nombre est bien
de réaliser à peu près toutes les
fonctions qu'on peut imaginer
l'intuition de mcculloch et pitt c'est
qu'en plus elle peut être capable
d'apprendre
contrairement aux autres approches
logique avec des opérateurs qui font
d'ailleurs l'électronique moderne et
bien cette machine là serait capable
d'apprendre comme notre cerveau comme
nous nous sommes capables d'apprendre en
vous voyez faits remontent déjà plus de
60 ans est bien un autre américain frank
rosenblatt invente en quelque sorte la
première machine ou va essayer de mettre
en rapport
plusieurs de ces neurones sous une
architecture extrêmement simple très
régulière des entrées qui vont prendre
et bien la perception du réseau une
couche interne qui va en quelque sorte
effectuer les calculs et une couche de
sortie il démontre encore une fois que
cette machine est potentiellement
capable de calculer tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer
le seul hic c'est que on ne sait pas
encore lui apprendre correctement en
fait on a très peu d'idées de la manière
dont on pourrait apprendre à cette
machine
on a bien sûr des idées mais en pratique
elle ne fonctionne pas il va falloir
attendre les années 1980 il est
découvert d'un français en particulier
yann lequin et puis d'un d'un canadien à
toronto géorgie hinton pour finalement
trouver l'algorithme qui va nous
permettre d'apprendre à ces machines
mais trouver l'algorithme théoriquement
ça suffit pas ce n'est que très
récemment en fait 2012-2013 qu'on a
compris comment l'utiliser correctement
et c'est pour ça qu'on est dans une
période nouvel âge d'or de
l'intelligence artificielle ou les
applications tout un ensemble
d'applications devient enfin possible
donc avec cette ce type de machine
est-ce qu'on pourrait
coder quelque chose qui nous fasse
penser à des émotions et bien ça a été
l'objet d'un des projets qu'on a menée
et une manière d'y arriver c'est ce
métabolisme émotionnel c'est de
s'inspirer bien sûr celui du vivant
celui des hommes je vais pas voulu
l'écrire en détail mais relativement
succinctement on entre les stimuler il
ya une partie intégration et finalement
le métabolisme émotionnel il va jouer à
trois niveaux celui de la personnalité
on a une personne on a tous une
personnalité différente on est
introverti extraverti et c'est un
deuxième niveau c'est toutes les
émotions qui sont qui durera une
quinzaine une vingtaine de secondes
et puis enfin les émotions instantané
toutes les émotions qu'on va comme la
surprise par exemple qui va être qui va
résulter de d'un événement et on va
ensuite arrivé vers le d'élise à sion en
fait dans un espace à trois dimensions
excuse et tout ce que les émotions se
sont très riches et donc on va
représenter cette émotion en fonction
d'un certain nombre d'informations et on
va placer dans ce repaire en trois
dimensions et bien les principales
émotion au sommet et finalement ce
finalement l'émotion de la créature
artificielle de l'intelligence
artificielle va être un point qui va se
balader en fonction des stimuli dans cet
espace à trois dimensions
donc on va pouvoir évoluer de l'intérêt
à la joie à la détresse à la colère en
fonction de ce qui est en train de se
passer
on a décidé avec un ami florent
aziosmanoff qui est un artiste et auteur
est bien de tester ses idées dans un
projet et on s'est attaqué là on n'a pas
eu peur on a osé comme on a dit dans la
première partie à s'attaquer d une des
pièces maîtresses de l'histoire dollars
la joconde de léonard de vinci
elle nous a toujours tous inspiré un sur
ce ce regard étrange sourire énigmatique
donc poursuivre dans ce contexte l'idée
du projet de léonard de vinci nous
paraissait
nous paraissait intéressant donc comment
on a fait et bien on a réalisé une
installation dans lequel le spectateur
peut-être face à une semblait
étrangement au tableau de léonard de
vinci
exactement à la même taille avec un
écran donc il va reproduire cette le
tableau de léonard de vinci
exactement à la taille donc dans un
premier temps les spectateurs s'approche
du tableau et croyant à avoir une copie
pas l'original vous savez combien c'est
difficile de la déplacer cette dame
donc voilà on est par contre quand ils
vont commencer à bouger il a eu à se
passer un centre de chaudes on va capter
les mouvements des spectateurs et ça va
modifier le métabolisme émotionnel de
notre mona lisa virtuel et ça va influer
évidemment sur sa représentation dans le
tableau donc c'est ça le principe on
capte ce qui se passe devant le tableau
ces stimuli qui sont bio inspirée on
s'est inspiré le fonctionnement de notre
cerveau sont intégrés dans un réseau de
neurones un peu spécial et qui va en
fait commander l'expression des émotions
sur une infographie en trois dimensions
beaucoup de une équipe d'étudiants assez
conséquente l'a réussi à travailler sur
ce modèle pour obtenir une qualité
proche je dirais en tout cas qui peut
nous tromper que lorsqu'on regarde le
tableau à une certaine distance
donc qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ceci
a donné et on l'a présenté
il y à quelques temps déjà et je vous
laisse regarder le résultat
si je respire
m
propose une indication
ça dépend
c
le projet continue c'est un projet à
longue échéance bien sûr pour travailler
sur ce type de sujet je pense
sincèrement qu'on a réussi notre coup
avec avec cette living mona lisa parce
que au bout d'un certain temps quand on
interagit avec elle eh bien on se
souvient plus très bien du tableau
original qu'elle était finalement le
sourire énigmatique de mona lisa et on
la voit évoluer devant nous avec
toujours cet air étrange un peu parfois
moqueur et donc c'est relativement
intéressant là vous avez deux images par
exemple d'expression qu'on obtient
lorsqu on interagit avec avec mona lisa
vous avez remarqué qu'on a essayé d'être
le plus respectueux de l'oeuvre
également un mona lisa fait pas de
grimaces elle ne se lève pas et le elle
ne fais pas de gestes spectaculaires on
reste toujours dans le contexte de
l'oeuvre souhaité par léonard de vinci
donc finalement la question est-ce
qu'une machine est ce qu une
intelligence artificielle peut ressentir
des émotions au travers de cette
expérience qu'est ce canton a conclu une
masse qu'on en a conclu c'est que
finalement est-ce qu'une machine peut
ressentir des émotions
déjà c'est une question qui n'a pas de
sens parce que la machine ne ressens
rien la machine n'est pas vivante et
donc ça c'est important le premier point
sahel cette expérience nous a démontré
que par contre on pouvait et bien capter
les émotions des spectateurs on pouvait
reproduire les émotions dans un tableau
d'une manière extrêmement réaliste qu'on
pouvait avoir un métabolisme
émotionnelle qui simulaient les émotions
de la vie de la mona lisa virtuel mais
en aucun cas même si on projette
énormément de choses sur les robots sur
ce type de système interactif la machine
elle ne ressent absolument rien on peut
simuler mais elle ne ressent rien et
donc c'est très important à une époque
où l'intelligence artificielle envahi
notre quotidien en tout cas il va le
faire
l'événement le plus spectaculaire dans
les prochaines années sera probablement
celui de l'avènement de la voiture
autonome
c'est une intelligence artificielle
star aux beaux arts où est donc cette
histoire des émotions est importante
c'est aussi important de réfléchir à
notre place finalement dans dans cette
évolution qui est qui est très
importante dans les années qui viennent
et je tiens beaucoup à expliquer c'est
ce que j'essaye de faire aujourd'hui
finalement et bien cette histoire
d'émotion elle est beaucoup plus
importante qu'on peut imaginer puisque
les machines ne ressentent pas des
émotions
cela signifie que l'homme a toujours sa
place dans ces systèmes artificiels
il faut systématiquement que l'homme
soit dans la boucle pour rapporter 7
cette dimension humaine
cette vie que n'ont pas ses systèmes
dans les machines merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e